hello team is in town this weekend we
right now Tim tried to do a flaming
butterbeer shot last night good a fire
everywhere you deserve a drink and it
didn't work so well so now we're gonna
do the actual version of it right here
right now the worst thing ever because
he uses Corona instead of well it's
either your refrigerator only has
gorilla okay so you need to use a Coors
Light
aka a shootie shitty beard all right so
we're gonna take this and we're gonna
pour it I'm already afraid of the fire I
guess okay fire
will you yeah okay so we're gonna pour
half and half butterscotch schnapps into
these shot glasses again you can see the
full recipe on you deserve a drink
flaming butter beer 3/4 of the way full
of butterscotch schnapps a lot of
schnapps this is what's gonna make it
taste delicious okay okay then a tiny
little bit of Bacardi because this is
flammable
okay look right on top we're gonna take
some matches from the grilling pub at
Pine Hill I don't know where
came from the Pine Hill Golf Course okay
hold your thing wait wait it's not going
to be okay one at the bottom
ish no no like that like that okay okay
so that's on fire right up caramelize
that mine is on fire it's okay
everything's okay okay okay take your
beer on the count of three we're gonna
drop it into the beer and chug the beer
okay one two three
kill me please to the bottom of it I
would say like the first four bits of it
is delicious